Argentina's presidential candidates
attempt a last push ahead of October's
presidential elections five candidates
from the left to the far right but there
are three with real chances of winning
economy Minister Sergio Masa promising
to reduce the double-digit inflation
rate that his government has been unable
to tackle
former security minister Patricia
Woolrich vowing to organize the economy
and far-right candidate Javier melaye
who wants to shut down the central bank
and dollarize the economy
Argentina is in decadence and if we
continue like this we are going to be
the biggest slum in the world Argentina
started being the richest country in the
world now we are among the poorest we
have more than 40 percent of poverty 10
percent are extremely poor and inflation
is out of control
melee tried to look composed and serious
and like his latest appearances where he
showed up with a chainsaw
Argentina has one of the highest
inflation rates in the world Sergio Masa
asked for forgiveness for the economic
situation and blamed the international
monetary fund
criminal Argentina inherited a criminal
agreement with the international
monetary fund that generates inflation
and four months ago we were able to
renegotiate and this is what allowed us
to reduce taxes
Masa is promising a national Accord to
get the country out of the crisis but
Patricia Woolrich from the center right
said people in Argentina are on the edge
and need order and stability
explained to the argentinians how being
the worst minister of economy you can be
a good president how can you be two
persons and have so much cynicism you
imposed 40 taxes you did everything
wrong doubles the inflation rate the
exchange rate
the focus was on the two candidates that
Paul suggest could make it to the second
round in November
Sergio Masa and Javier Miley who blamed
all the politicians for what he called
Argentina's economic disaster
this was the first of two debates ahead
of the elections on October 22nd
Argentina is in the middle of a deep
economic crisis and there's lots of
anxiety about who this country's next
president is going to be and while there
are many who are hoping for radical
change there are many others who fear
what that change could bring about there
is
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera